This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Anyone who has listened to this show knows that I love stories from history. One of the things I love the most is that a history story in and of itself has a certain value, but what's amazing is how much the current situation that you're hearing the story affects how it's understood. It's like adding a musical score to a scene in a movie, the mood of the current moment changes our interpretation of everything. This is all leading me to introduce him to a brand new history show that we have premiering today from radio topia. It's produced and hosted by the
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。任何听过这个节目的人都知道我热爱历史故事。我最喜欢的一点是，历史故事本身就具有一定的价值，但令人惊奇的是，你听故事时所处的当前环境，在多大程度上影响了你对故事的理解。这就像给电影场景配乐一样，当下的情绪改变了我们对一切的解读。这一切促使我向大家介绍一个我们今天在Radiotopia首播的全新历史节目。它由
immensely talented and recently in the stashyode Jody Avergan, who you may know from ESPN's 30-for-30 podcast and he was the host of the 538 Politics podcast for many years. I'm a huge fan of Jody. I'm so excited he's joining the team. And so on this episode, I'll talk with him in premiere two episodes of his new podcast, this day in esoteric political history. Hey, Jody.
才华横溢且最近刚加入的乔迪·阿弗根制作并主持，你可能从ESPN的《30 for 30》播客中认识他，他多年来一直是《538政治》播客的主持人。我是乔迪的超级粉丝。我非常高兴他能加入团队。所以在这期节目中，我将与他交谈，并首播他的新播客《这一天的深奥政治史》的前两集。嘿，乔迪。
Hello there, Roman. So for context, we're talking on Friday, March 27th. Each and our respective homes, me and California, for context, we're talking on Friday, March 27th, each in our respective homes, me in California, you in New York City, and we're going to talk about your new show on radio atopia. That's right. I'm really excited to join radio atopia. I just want to confirm, though, I'm recording in my bedroom, which has two windows.
你好，罗曼。为了交代背景，我们是在3月27日星期五进行录制的。我们各自在家中，我在加州，你在纽约市，我们要谈谈你在Radiotopia的新节目。没错。我真的很高兴能加入Radiotopia。不过我想确认一下，我是在我的卧室里录音的，那里有两扇窗户。
You're recording in your bedroom, which I believe listeners learned in a previous episode, has five windows, which are for windows. It's five windows. I live on the corner, my, my, and my bedroom is on the corner of the house. And so it has five windows, which makes it very good for son, very bad for recording quite the truth. I thought, I thought both of those things. I got immediately jealous. And then I got immediately started to do the calculus of how is he making this room quiet?
你在卧室里录音，我相信听众在上一集已经知道，那里有五扇窗户，而不是两扇。是五扇窗户。我住在拐角处，我的卧室在房子的拐角。所以它有五扇窗户，这对阳光来说非常好，但对录音来说非常糟糕。确实如此。我当时想，我当时想到了这两点。我立刻感到嫉妒。然后我立刻开始计算他到底是怎么让这个房间安静下来的？
It's a little brave of you to admit. It was brave of you to admit as much on the national radio show. But anyway, the task at hand, yes, I'm joining radio topil, which I'm incredibly excited about. We're doing a new show that it's called This Day in Esoteric Political History. Basically a couple times a week, I'm going to get together with a historian Nicole Hemmer, and we're going to have special guests along the way as well, and look at one item, one moment that happened on that day in political history. And the show is going to be short. It's going to be under 10 minutes each time,
你在全国性的广播节目中承认这一点，真是有点勇敢。无论如何，言归正传，是的，我加入了Radiotopia，我对此感到无比兴奋。我们正在做一个新节目，叫《这一天的深奥政治史》。基本上每周几次，我会和历史学家妮可·海默聚在一起，我们也会邀请特别嘉宾，看看政治史上那一天发生的一件事。节目会很短，每次不到10分钟，
and we're just going to try and kind of pick a bunch of moments big and small that are either interesting stories, but I suspect we'll also have some things to teach us about this moment that we're going through right now. Yeah. I mean, one of the things I've noticed in the conversation about coronavirus and even Trump, as we've been talking about, Trump for the past couple of years, is we've been falling back on this idea that all this is unprecedented. And I think that helps describe the enormity of everything,
我们只是想挑选一些大大小小的时刻，它们要么是有趣的故事，但我猜它们也会教给我们一些关于我们现在所经历的这个时刻的东西。是的。我的意思是，在关于冠状病毒甚至特朗普的对话中，正如我们过去几年一直在谈论特朗普的那样，我注意到的一件事是，我们一直陷入这样一种观念，即这一切都是前所未有的。我认为这有助于描述一切的严重性，
but I don't think that description is very helpful beyond that. I think it's a much more useful approach to find little threads of connections that are unprecedented so that we can continue to learn and evolve and respond. And that's why I'm really excited about this day in esoteric political history. How do you see the role of the things that you will tell stories about and how they connect
但我认为这种描述除此之外并没有多大帮助。我认为一个更有用的方法是找到那些并非前所未有的细微联系，这样我们才能继续学习、进化和应对。这就是为什么我对《这一天的深奥政治史》感到非常兴奋。你如何看待你将讲述的故事的角色，以及它们如何与
with the modern world? I think it's born of the very same instinct that I think a lot of you have had. And I've had both as a journalist and just as a human being to find myself thinking long before coronavirus, you know, over the last four or five years or so, saying, man, this feels new. This feels unprecedented. It feels like we're completely new territory. And I think like a lot of people, I have found myself turning to history more and more to get some guidance and get some guardrails. And you know, I've come to think that there's basically three main ways in which history can help us understand this moment.
现代世界联系起来？我认为这源于我所认为的你们很多人都有的同样的本能。作为一名记者，也作为一个普通人，我发现自己在冠状病毒爆发前很久，也就是过去四五年左右，就一直在想，天哪，这感觉很新鲜。这感觉前所未有。感觉我们完全处于新的领域。我想像很多人一样，我发现自己越来越多地转向历史，以获得一些指导和护栏。你知道，我开始认为历史可以帮助我们理解这一时刻的方式主要有三种。
And one is to say, no, this isn't new. This has happened before. Look at this time, this time, and this time, when basically this exact thing happened before. And there's comfort in that. There really is. That's not to diminish the sort of seriousness of what's happening now or given incident. Then there's the second category which is, oh no, this really is new. And
第一种是说，不，这不是新的。这以前发生过。看看这个时间，那个时间，还有那个时间，基本上完全相同的事情以前发生过。这让人感到安慰。确实如此。这并不是要削弱现在正在发生的事情或特定事件的严重性。然后是第二类，即，哦不，这确实是新的。而且
there are moments like that. I don't want to dismiss that, you know, but I think understanding when you need to raise the alarm and say, oh my gosh, we are in uncharted territory. The third category is the one that I've really fascinated by. And I think I've really come around to and I think I want to try and explore in the show, which is things may be new. We may be in uncharted territory, but this moment is a product of history. The conditions that have built up in this country over the last 20, 30, 50, 100 years have led us to this moment. And that, I think, is the thing we don't talk about enough.
确实有这样的时刻。我不想否认这一点，你知道，但我认为理解何时需要敲响警钟并说，天哪，我们处于未知领域，这一点很重要。第三类是我真正着迷的，我想我真的已经转变了观念，我想在节目中探索它，那就是事情可能是新的。我们可能处于未知领域，但这一时刻是历史的产物。过去20、30、50、100年来在这个国家积累的条件导致了我们现在的时刻。我认为，这才是我们谈论得不够的事情。
How what we are feeling is completely new and unprecedented and sort of out of nowhere is actually a product of what has happened in this country. And it's almost inevitable given the forces that have shaped politics in this country over the last, you know, future generations. Right. So we're gonna play a couple episodes
我们所感受到的那种完全新鲜、前所未有且似乎凭空出现的东西，实际上是这个国家过去所发生之事的产物。考虑到过去塑造这个国家政治的力量，这几乎是不可避免的，你知道，对于未来几代人来说。好的，所以我们将播放几集
of this day in esoteric political history. One of the things I love about the name is when I was feeling the same need to sort of examine the world and put out a podcast by diving into history, I call it. What Trump can teach us about Khan Law? I thought of that too. Which is equally comfortable. And you throw off the tongue. Well, I also appreciate that you in Slack recently tried to like acronym,
《这一天的深奥政治史》。我喜欢这个名字的原因之一是，当我感到同样的需要去审视世界并通过深入历史来发布播客时，我称之为《特朗普能教给我们什么关于宪法的事？》。我也想到了那个。同样令人舒适。而且朗朗上口。好吧，我也很欣赏你最近在Slack上试图缩写它，
acronymize it or whatever, T-D-I-N-O, and I saw that I was like, no, we're not going to be doing that. T-D-H. This day maybe. Yeah, so this day in esoteric political history, so we're going to play a couple episodes of this day in esoteric political history, and the first one, can you tell us about what happened on this day and sort of T-Up, the story that we're going to hear first? Yeah, so on March 31st, we're going to be talking about March 31st, 1968, which is when Lyndon B. Johnson, a sitting president, incumbent president, in an incredibly tumultuous year
或者别的什么，T-D-I-N-O，我看到了，我就想，不，我们不会那样做。T-D-H。这一天也许。是的，所以《这一天的深奥政治史》，我们将播放几集《这一天的深奥政治史》，第一集，你能告诉我们这一天发生了什么，并为我们即将听到的故事做个铺垫吗？好的，所以在3月31日，我们将讨论1968年3月31日，当时林登·B·约翰逊，一位在任总统，在1968年这个极其动荡的年份，
in 1968, he announces that he's not seeking re-election. We're going to be visiting 1968. I suspect a lot over the course of this series, but this was obviously a big event when a president, only a second time ever, that a president says he's not going to seek re-election, and it just sort of gives us a sense for what it feels like to be in the midst of a really tumultuous year. And I think we're certainly feeling that right now. Okay, let's hear it. and I think we're certainly feeling that right now. Okay, let's hear it.
宣布他不寻求连任。我们将在本系列节目中多次访问1968年，但这显然是一个重大事件，一位总统，这是有史以来第二次，宣布他不寻求连任，这让我们感受到身处一个非常动荡的年份是什么感觉。我想我们现在肯定有这种感觉。好的，让我们听听吧。
Hello and welcome to this day in esoteric political history from radiotopia. My name is Jody Avergan. This day March 31, 1968, LBJ's surprise announcement that he is not seeking re-election. We're joined as always. Well, this is the first time actually, but we're joined by Nicole Hemer of Columbia Nikki. I'm very excited to be doing this series with you and this is our first episode. Hi. Yeah, I'm really excited about it. So I know we call this show Esoteric, political history. We will hit all sorts of different types of stories, but this is obviously a big moment, a president announcing that he will not seek reelection. And I guess one thing is I can hear our more lefty listeners here in 2020,
你好，欢迎收听来自Radiotopia的《这一天的深奥政治史》。我是乔迪·阿弗根。这一天是1968年3月31日，LBJ（林登·B·约翰逊）出人意料地宣布他不寻求连任。我们像往常一样加入了……好吧，这实际上是第一次，但我们有哥伦比亚大学的妮可·海默加入。妮基，我很高兴能和你一起做这个系列，这是我们的第一集。嗨。是的，我对此感到非常兴奋。所以我知道我们把这个节目称为深奥的政治史。我们将涉及各种不同类型的故事，但这显然是一个重大时刻，一位总统宣布他将不寻求连任。我想我可以听到我们2020年那些更左翼的听众在这里，
maybe a little hopefully saying to themselves, wait a minute, I'm battle president in a moment of crisis, you can just announce that you're out that you no longer want to run. How often does this happen? Yeah, it doesn't happen very often. Don't be your hopes to. I think it happened one other time with Truman. Um, and like LBJ,
也许带着一点希望对自己说，等一下，在危机时刻的现任总统，你可以直接宣布你退出了，你不再想竞选了？这种情况多久发生一次？是的，这种情况并不常发生。别抱太大希望。我想这种情况只在杜鲁门身上发生过一次。嗯，就像LBJ一样，
he had a little bit of extra time at the beginning of his term, because he was a vice president who inherited the presidency. So let me lay out some of the basics of this story, and then we'll come around to kind of what we think it means and some more. But LBJ made this announcement at the end of a 40 minute
他在任期开始时有一点额外的时间，因为他是一位继承了总统职位的副总统。所以让我列出这个故事的一些基本情况，然后我们会谈谈我们认为它意味着什么以及更多内容。但LBJ是在一次40分钟的演讲结束时做出这个宣布的，
address from the Oval Office. It was ostensibly an update about the Vietnam War. But then at the end of his address, he famously says, I shall not seek and will not accept the nomination of my party for another term as president. He, as you mentioned, taken over for Kennedy after the assassination in 1963. He trounced goldwater in the 64 election. What else? The Civil Rights Act, his domestic agenda, but by this point, Vietnam is really the thing that is sort of swamping his presidency, right? Yeah, it's something that I think is hard to wrap our minds around when
演讲是在椭圆形办公室发表的。表面上是关于越南战争的最新情况。但在演讲结束时，他著名地说道：“我不寻求，也不会接受我的党派提名的另一个总统任期。”正如你提到的，他在1963年肯尼迪遇刺后接任。他在64年的选举中击败了戈德华特。还有什么？《民权法案》，他的国内议程，但到这一点，越南战争确实是那种正在淹没他总统任期的东西，对吧？是的，我认为这很难让我们理解，当
we've been at war for 20 years now, and the wars that we're in just don't intrude in most people's daily lives. But Vietnam was a lot different. It was part of people's daily lives. They would listen to a 40 minute address from the president and it affected everything that was happening in America at the time. Well, you know, I'm having conversations with my parents these days and with this pandemic there, sort of talking about how this is the first time in a long time since Vietnam where they have felt like there's an issue that is touching every American. I mean, the story of war, I'm sure we'll track this over the course of the show,
我们已经打了20年仗，而我们所处的战争并没有侵入大多数人的日常生活。但越南战争则大不相同。它是人们日常生活的一部分。他们会听总统的40分钟演讲，它影响了当时在美国发生的一切。嗯，你知道，我这些天在和我的父母交谈，随着这场大流行，他们谈论这如何是自越南战争以来很长一段时间内，他们第一次感到有一个问题触及了每个美国人。我的意思是，战争的故事，我相信我们会在节目中追踪这一点，
but the story of war is that it's become more and more separated from the lives of daily American. I think that's such a good point because even something like the September 11 attacks, which I think most Americans had a really visceral reaction to were localized, right? It was Pennsylvania, New York, and DC, and the actual events were only taking place in small parts of the United States, whereas this is going to come to every city and town in America. So a little more about this announcement by Johnson. He had health issues. He had had gallbladder and kidney stone surgeries, heart issues, he actually died four years later.
但战争的故事是它变得越来越脱离美国人的日常生活。我认为这是一个很好的观点，因为即使是像9月11日袭击事件这样我认为大多数美国人都有强烈反应的事情，也是局部性的，对吧？那是宾夕法尼亚州、纽约和华盛顿特区，实际事件只发生在美国的一小部分地区，而这（疫情）将波及美国的每个城市和城镇。所以关于约翰逊的这个声明再多说一点。他有健康问题。他做过胆囊和肾结石手术，有心脏问题，他实际上在四年后去世了。
He had apparently come close to making this announcement in October, December and January, and finally did it here. There's reporting that it wasn't in the advanced text, so I mean, the circle people who knew this was incredibly small and it really did come as a shock. I heard some people even thought it may have been in April Fool's joke because it happened on March 31st.
他显然在10月、12月和1月曾接近做出这个宣布，最终在这里做到了。有报道称这不在预先准备的文本中，所以我的意思是，知道这一点的人圈子非常小，这确实令人震惊。我听说有些人甚至认为这可能是愚人节玩笑，因为它发生在3月31日。
Right, I mean, I think that it was far too serious a speech for it to be an April Fool's joke. That would be a pretty messed up issue. It would be, it would be. And things were pretty dire when it came to Vietnam at that point. I mean, just a few months earlier, the TED Offensive had been launched,
对，我的意思是，我认为那是一次太严肃的演讲，不可能是愚人节玩笑。那将是一个非常糟糕的问题。确实会是。而且在越南问题上，当时的情况相当严峻。我的意思是，就在几个月前，春节攻势刚刚发起，
which really showed Americans that the war was not going their way. And also that military and political leaders weren't telling them the truth about the war. And that had a real effect on Johnson's approval ratings. Here he is starting up his bid for reelection and his approval ratings at the time of the speech were something like 30% of people approved of him. It was really low. But then what happens when he announces that he's not going to seek reelection? All of a sudden people love him.
这确实向美国人表明战争并没有按他们的意愿发展。而且军事和政治领导人也没有告诉他们关于战争的真相。这对约翰逊的支持率产生了真正的影响。他当时正在开始竞选连任，而他在演讲时的支持率大约只有30%的人支持他。这真的很低。但当他宣布不寻求连任时发生了什么？突然之间人们爱上了他。
Once they know they don't have to put up with him anymore, Americans flip. They go from 57% disapproving of him to 57% of them approving of him. Yes, that would not happen today. I mean, you look at approval rating. And they're so steady and they're so dictated by polarization and partisanship. That I don't think we will see swings like that that inherently mean people are crossing party lines in their approval. Yeah, I mean, that's been the remarkable thing about the Trump presidency is how stable approval ratings have been throughout.
一旦他们知道他们不必再忍受他了，美国人就转变了。他们从57%的不支持他变成了57%的支持他。是的，这种情况今天不会发生。我的意思是，你看看支持率，它们是如此稳定，并且如此受两极分化和党派偏见的影响。我不认为我们会看到那种本质上意味着人们跨越党派界限来表达支持的波动。是的，我的意思是，特朗普总统任期最引人注目的一点就是支持率一直保持稳定。
If you go back earlier in the mid-20th century, you saw wide ranges of approval and you saw presidents like Dwight Eisenhower, who was a Republican, pretty regularly getting 70% public approval. So it was a very, very different time then. Yeah. So in his remarks, he kind of hints at this thing that got me thinking about the fact that he has to focus on all of the challenges before him. And then he is also being asked to run for reelection. And he basically says, I can't do both of these things. So I am going to try and do my job until the end of this year. And someone else can decide to campaign. What does it mean that
如果你回到20世纪中叶，你会看到广泛的支持率范围，你会看到像德怀特·艾森豪威尔这样的总统，他是一名共和党人，相当经常地获得70%的公众支持。所以那是一个非常、非常不同的时代。是的。所以他在讲话中暗示了这一点，这让我想到他必须专注于他面前的所有挑战。然后他还被要求竞选连任。他基本上说，我不能同时做这两件事。所以我将尝试在今年年底前做好我的工作。而其他人可以决定竞选。这意味着什么，
we ask these presidents to campaign in their last year in this way? You know, the crises of the world don't care that it's an election year. They just show up and they can show up in the last year for presidency as easily as they can show up in the first year. It's an extreme challenge to both juggle the presidency, which in the right hands is a full-time job, and then layer over campaigning on top of it. It's hard to do both really well and to not confuse the two. I mean, I think that's where people often get in trouble is when you have to deal with a major crisis,
我们要求这些总统以这种方式在他们的最后一年竞选？你知道，世界的危机并不关心这是选举年。它们只是出现，它们可以在总统任期的最后一年像在第一年一样容易地出现。既要兼顾总统职位（在合适的人手中这是一份全职工作），又要在此基础上进行竞选，这是一个极大的挑战。很难把这两件事都做得很好，而且不把两者混为一谈。我的意思是，我认为这就是人们经常遇到麻烦的地方，当你有重大危机要处理时，
but now you also have to go speak to deep pocketed donors at a $5,000 fundraisers somewhere. Certainly, I think we have a president now who thinks he's at his best when he's in campaigning mode and I think thinks of everything basically as a campaign. Has anyone ever tried to like split these two? A little bit. So if we think about the Obama reelection campaign in 2012, he took his entire sort of reelection campaign and he sent all of his people to Chicago and they were going to run the reelection from there and he was going to be governing in DC. And I think that that kind of splitting, there's only so much that you can do, right? It's ultimately a fiction, but that's one attempt to do it.
但现在你还得去参加某处5000美元入场费的筹款活动，去和那些财大气粗的捐赠者交谈。当然，我认为我们现在的总统认为他在竞选模式下表现最好，而且我认为他基本上把一切都看作是一场竞选。有人尝试过把这两者分开吗？有一点。如果我们回想2012年奥巴马的连任竞选，他把整个连任竞选团队的人都派到了芝加哥，让他们在那里负责竞选，而他则在华盛顿特区执政。我认为这种分离，能做的也就这么多了，对吧？这最终是一种虚构，但这是尝试这样做的一种方式。
I want to wrap up with a kind of big question about 1968 and these other moments in history that feel incredibly tumultuous. So you look at 1968 and you say, goodness, you know, wars, riots, assassinations, presidents not running for re-election. Some of these are obviously linked to each other, but I guess I'm trying to figure out whether there are just these errors of overall instability, where it's just one of those years in which big messy epic things are going to happen, maybe even if they aren't directly tied to each other. Do these things kind of tend to group? So that's a good question. The answer is sort of yes and no. I'm not sure that the assassination of Martin Luther King led to the assassination of Bobby Kennedy But if we take a kind of bigger picture look at things instead of looking just at 68 like look at the 60s as a whole
我想用一个关于1968年以及历史上其他感觉极其动荡的时刻的大问题来结束。你看看1968年，你会说，天哪，你知道，战争、骚乱、暗杀、总统不寻求连任。其中一些显然是相互关联的，但我猜我想弄清楚的是，是否仅仅存在这种整体不稳定的时代，即在这些年份里，重大的、混乱的、史诗般的事件必然会发生，即使它们之间没有直接联系。这些事情往往会集中在一起吗？这是一个好问题。答案是既是也不是。我不确定马丁·路德·金的遇刺是否导致了鲍比·肯尼迪的遇刺。但如果我们从更宏观的角度来看，而不是仅仅盯着68年，而是把60年代作为一个整体来看
There had been a lot of fractures forming for The whole decade right you had the Cuban Missile Crisis which had the whole world on the brink of nuclear apocalypse. You had the assassination of John Kennedy. You had the Civil Rights Movement and racist murders and violence that were happening pretty regularly, urban uprisings. So by the time 1968 rolls around, a lot of the things that happen are kind of over-determined because of all of these fractures that had been caused earlier. I remember in 2016, we had a few conversations on the 538 politics podcast, which I did during that election, that were basically, is this 1968?
整个十年里已经出现了许多裂痕，对吧？你有古巴导弹危机，让全世界处于核末日的边缘。你有约翰·肯尼迪的遇刺。你有民权运动，以及经常发生的种族主义谋杀和暴力事件，还有城市起义。所以当1968年到来时，很多发生的事情在某种程度上是预先注定的，因为之前已经造成了所有这些裂痕。我记得在2016年，我们在538政治播客上进行过几次对话，那是我在选举期间做的，基本上就是问，这是1968年吗？
And I think what I'm realizing in retrospect was that, you know, 2016 was not our 1968. It was the beginning of the sort of process that you just described, and maybe now, four years later, we're having our 1968. Yeah, if you think about all of the things people have pointed to as weaknesses in the American system revealed by 2016, we're now in a moment with a pandemic where all of those weaknesses are starting to cause even bigger and more catastrophic problems. Well, on that cheery note, we will end our first episode. That is it for today, Nicole. Thank you very much.
我想我事后意识到的是，你知道，2016年并不是我们的1968年。它是你刚才描述的那种进程的开始，也许现在，四年后，我们正在经历我们的1968年。是的，如果你想想人们指出的2016年所揭示的美国体系的所有弱点，我们现在正处于一个大流行的时刻，所有这些弱点都开始引发更大、更灾难性的问题。好吧，带着这个令人愉快的音符，我们将结束我们的第一集。今天就到这里，妮可。非常感谢你。
Thanks so much, Jodie. This was fun. Now, how can you get in touch with us and be part of this show? You just need to remember one thing, this day pod. I'm quite proud of myself over the last couple of weeks. I have secured this day pod on every possible medium. So that is our website, thisdaypod.com.
非常感谢，朱迪。这很有趣。现在，你如何与我们联系并参与这个节目？你只需要记住一件事，this day pod。在过去几周里，我对自己感到非常自豪。我已经确保在所有可能的媒介上都能找到this day pod。所以这就是我们的网站，thisdaypod.com。
You can email us this day pod at gmail.com and our social handles on Twitter possible medium. So that is our website, thisdaypod.com. You can email us, this day pod at gmail.com and our social handles on Twitter and Instagram. You can find those, this day pod. If you have any suggestions for future topics or dates or comments at all, do get in touch with us. This day in esoteric political history is a proud member of radio topia from PRX. This was our first first episode so we want to thank everyone at PRX, including Executive Producer Julie Shapiro for bringing us on board. This is a moment when I think we're all realizing the power and the need for community, so we just feel really honored to be on board and part of that community. Our researcher and producer is Jacob Feldman.
你可以发邮件给我们 this day pod at gmail.com，以及我们在Twitter上的社交账号。所以这就是我们的网站，thisdaypod.com。你可以发邮件给我们，this day pod at gmail.com，以及我们在Twitter和Instagram上的社交账号。你可以找到它们，this day pod。如果你对未来的主题或日期有任何建议，或者有任何评论，请务必与我们联系。This day in esoteric political history 是PRX旗下Radiotopia的骄傲成员。这是我们的第一集，所以我们要感谢PRX的每一个人，包括执行制片人朱莉·夏皮罗（Julie Shapiro）让我们加入。这是一个我认为我们都意识到社区的力量和需求的时刻，所以我们感到非常荣幸能加入并成为那个社区的一部分。我们的研究员和制片人是雅各布·费尔德曼（Jacob Feldman）。
Our music is from Blue Dot Sessions, remixed by Jameson Isaac aka Teen Days. Our artwork is by Kate LaRue. Next episode we'll discuss something that's probably on your mind, pandemics, and the time 100 years ago when a president got hit with the flu on negotiating the end of a world war. My name is Jody Evergan, thanks again for listening, and we'll see you soon. My name is Jody Evergan, thanks again for listening, and we'll see you soon. With American sons in the field far away, with America's future under challenge right here at home, I do not believe that I should devote an hour or a day of my time to any duties other than the awesome duties of this office.
我们的音乐来自Blue Dot Sessions，由Jameson Isaac（又名Teen Days）混音。我们的艺术作品由Kate LaRue创作。下一集我们将讨论一个可能让你心头萦绕的话题：大流行病，以及100年前一位总统在谈判结束世界大战时患上流感的那段时光。我的名字是朱迪·埃弗根（Jody Evergan），再次感谢你的收听，我们很快会再见。我的名字是朱迪·埃弗根，再次感谢你的收听，我们很快会再见。随着美国儿女在远方战场，随着美国的未来在本土受到挑战，我不认为我应该把我的时间花在除了这个办公室的神圣职责之外的任何职责上。
We have the world premiere of another full episode of this day in esoteric political history and more conversation with Jody Havvergan after this. So could you describe the second episode, which is really relevant to the time we're in right now? Yeah, so our second episode, which is coming out on Thursday, April 2nd, we'll play it for people here now, is about when Woodrow Wilson got the flu in 1918 as part of the influenza pandemic of 1918. Actually, he got it in 1919 on April 2nd. This is where I should confess that we are originally planning this show to be about
我们有《This day in esoteric political history》另一整集的全球首播，以及之后与朱迪·埃弗根的更多对话。那么你能描述一下第二集吗？它与我们现在所处的时代非常相关。是的，我们的第二集将于4月2日星期四播出，我们现在就为听众播放，是关于伍德罗·威尔逊（Woodrow Wilson）在1918年流感大流行期间患上流感的故事。实际上，他是在1919年4月2日患病的。这里我应该承认，我们最初计划这个节目是关于
just elections. We thought this was going to be a tumultuous election year and we thought we'd do stories from previous elections. And then we did sort of change a little bit when the coronavirus pandemic began to feel like, you know, what we want to make space for other stories in politics, other moments of crisis, other moments when this country has faced things like this. And so we've brought in the scope a little bit, and this is an example of a kind of thing that wasn't necessarily an election year, but obviously a moment when our politics had to react to a pandemic. And, you know, I think one simple reminder is that Wilson got the flu, the president of the United States got the flu basically full year after
仅仅是选举。我们以为这将是一个动荡的选举年，我们想讲述以前选举的故事。然后当冠状病毒大流行开始时，我们确实改变了一点，觉得，你知道，我们想为政治中的其他故事、其他危机时刻、这个国家曾经面临过类似事情的其他时刻留出空间。所以我们稍微扩大了范围，这是一个例子，它不一定是一个选举年，但显然是一个我们的政治必须对大流行病做出反应的时刻。而且，你知道，我想一个简单的提醒是，威尔逊得了流感，美国总统得了流感，基本上是在
the pandemic had started. And it's a simple reminder that these things come in waves and these things go for a while. Yeah, let's hear it. come in waves and these things go for a while. Yeah, let's see. Hello and welcome to this day in esoteric political history from radiotopia. My name is Jody Avergan. This day, April 2, 1919, Woodrow Wilson has the flu. The influenza pandemic is sometimes called the
大流行开始整整一年后。这是一个简单的提醒，这些事情是分波次来的，并且会持续一段时间。是的，让我们听听。分波次来的，并且会持续一段时间。是的，让我们看看。你好，欢迎收听来自Radiotopia的《This day in esoteric political history》。我的名字是朱迪·埃弗根。今天，1919年4月2日，伍德罗·威尔逊患了流感。流感大流行有时被称为
1918 flu pandemic. It started in spring 1918, but it was the second wave, as we are all learning. In the fall of 1918, there was the most devastating, with the disease spreading into 1919. That is when President Wilson reportedly caught the flu either right before or right after he arrived in Paris for another round of talks to try and bring an end to the first world war. We're joined as always by Nicole Hammer of Columbia University. I'll lay out what we know and don't know about this moment in a second.
1918年流感大流行。它始于1918年春天，但正如我们所有人正在了解的那样，那是第二波。在1918年秋天，那是最具破坏性的一波，疾病一直蔓延到1919年。就在那时，威尔逊总统据报道患上了流感，要么是在他抵达巴黎进行新一轮谈判以试图结束第一次世界大战之前，要么是在之后。和往常一样，哥伦比亚大学的妮可·哈默（Nicole Hammer）加入了我们。我稍后会列出我们对这一时刻的了解和未知之处。
But we should say right off the bat, Nikki, that there's a little bit of controversy about whether he actually had the flu or there were some other things going on. Yeah, so one of the things that people know about Wilson and his health is that he suffers a pretty serious stroke near the end of his presidency. So for a long time, historians talked about this illness as a mini-stroke that he had had. But if you actually look at the set of symptoms that he had, including a really high fever, none of them really fit a stroke, and they all sound a whole lot like this pandemic that was ravaging the world at the time.
但我们应该开门见山地说，妮基，关于他是否真的得了流感，或者当时是否发生了其他事情，存在一些争议。是的，人们对威尔逊和他的健康状况了解的一件事是，他在总统任期结束时患上了相当严重的中风。所以长期以来，历史学家把这种疾病称为他患过的一次小中风。但如果你仔细观察他的一系列症状，包括非常高的发烧，它们都不太符合中风，而且听起来非常像当时席卷全球的那场大流行病。
Yeah, I mean, by all counts, and we'll talk a little bit about what the revocations of this were, but he was very out of it. He was fever-struck. He was sort of deteriorating rapidly over the course of these negotiations. In Paris, one thing that's interesting is that it was underplayed at the time, I guess. You know, there was these questions about whether it was actually flu, but did they try and cover this up, or was it just that sort of reports were murky? Like, what did people know at the time? Yeah, so when this was first reported, it was just reported that he had a cold. And this probably isn't surprising.
是的，我的意思是，从各方面来看，我们稍后会谈谈这带来的后果，但他当时非常神志不清。他发着高烧。在这些谈判过程中，他的状况似乎在迅速恶化。在巴黎，有趣的一点是，当时这件事被淡化了，我想。你知道，有人质疑这是否真的是流感，但他们是否试图掩盖这一点，还是说当时的报道很模糊？人们当时知道什么？是的，所以当这件事最初被报道时，只是说他感冒了。这可能并不令人惊讶。
I mean, was it a cover-up? You know, they didn't often tell in detail the kinds of illnesses that presidents had at the time. There's a much bigger cover-up that will happen later in his presidency about his health conditions. But in this case, not wanting to scare people in the midst of both a war and a pandemic, they decided to just say, hey, it's a cold, he'll be fine. So I want to get to some of the sort of bigger questions around this because for one, I mean, it's really kind of stunning how precarious of a situation this is.
我的意思是，这是一场掩盖吗？你知道，他们当时并不经常详细说明总统所患疾病的种类。在他总统任期后期，关于他的健康状况还有一场更大的掩盖。但在这种情况下，为了不让人们在战争和大流行病期间感到恐慌，他们决定只是说，嘿，只是感冒，他会好起来的。所以我想谈谈围绕这件事的一些更大的问题，因为首先，我的意思是，这种情况的危险程度确实令人震惊。
We have a leader at a meeting with all of the what is known as the big four who were negotiating the end of World War One. Wilson's doctor says quote, the whole of civilization seemed to hang in the balance. Is that a doctor being a little traumatic when he's writing his memoirs or I mean it's just one of really one of those moments? This is really one of those moments. I mean, here it is after the most devastating war that the world really had ever seen. And now they're trying to figure out how to bring it to a close. And somebody like Wilson, what have been the perfect person to have at that table?
我们有一位领导人在与所有被称为“四巨头”的人会面，他们正在谈判结束第一次世界大战。威尔逊的医生说，引用：“整个文明似乎都悬于一线。”这是医生在写回忆录时有点戏剧化，还是说这确实是那些时刻之一？这确实是那些时刻之一。我的意思是，这是在世界所见过的最具破坏性的战争之后。现在他们正试图弄清楚如何结束它。而像威尔逊这样的人，本该是坐在那张桌子旁的最完美的人选？
This is something he had been thinking about how to win the peace for a really long time. And now he shows up at the peace table and he's kind of a mess. Yeah. And I mean, it's like, it comes down to the fact that he just can't concentrate as well as he normally would. He just doesn't bring it and it's a reminder that we elect these people and we're electing real people who have to go into real meetings with other real people and what they say and how they behave in those actual meetings is just as important as you know all the policies and all the track record and all that stuff. It comes down to the sort of behavior in that moment. And I mean there are there are sort of theories about the fact that
这是他思考了很久如何赢得和平的事情。现在他出现在和平谈判桌上，却成了一团糟。是的。我的意思是，这归结为他无法像平时那样集中注意力。他没有发挥出水平，这提醒我们，我们选举这些人，我们选举的是真实的人，他们必须与其他真实的人进行真实的会议，他们在这些实际会议中所说的话和表现出的行为，与你知道的所有政策、所有过往记录等等一样重要。这归结为那一刻的行为。我的意思是，有一些理论认为
what we're one may have ended very differently had Wilson been on his a game in particular with regards to what happened to to Germans. Yeah, mean, one of the things that Wilson really wanted was a gentle piece with Germany. He was really worried about a vindictive piece that would be about score settling, because he knew that they needed to rebuild a peaceful functioning cooperative Europe after this, if they were going to maintain peace
如果威尔逊处于最佳状态，特别是关于德国发生了什么，第一次世界大战可能会以非常不同的方式结束。是的，我的意思是，威尔逊真正想要的是对德国的温和和平。他非常担心一种会清算旧账的报复性和平，因为他知道，如果他们想在战争结束后维持和平，他们就需要在此之后重建一个和平、运作良好、相互合作的欧洲。
beyond the end of this. functioning cooperative Europe after this, if they were going to maintain peace beyond the end of this. And you know, it was something that normally he would have pushed for. I mean, the flu is part of it. He also gets delivered a pretty devastating blow in the midterm elections of 1918, where Republicans sweep, and so there's a sense the country doesn't necessarily want everything that Wilson wants. But I mean, Jody, you've had the flu before.
在此之后重建一个和平、运作良好、相互合作的欧洲，如果他们想在战争结束后维持和平。你知道，这通常是他会推动的事情。我的意思是，流感是其中的一部分。他在1918年中期选举中也受到了相当沉重的打击，共和党人横扫，所以有一种感觉，国家并不一定想要威尔逊想要的一切。但我的意思是，朱迪，你以前得过流感。
Can you imagine going to this table with the three other leaders of these countries and barely being able to sit up much less, you know, argue forcefully for the thing that you believe in? So one big question, I mean, this is sort of stating the obvious, but I kind of want to end on this note, but like, you don't get to choose when pandemic's hit, right? And I think it gets to this larger theme that, you know, so much of a presidency is defined by things you can't plan for. And it's really about how do you react in that moment. And I mean, this seems like a perfect example of that. Yeah. I mean, the tendency at the time was the right thing to do is to downplay what's happening
你能想象带着流感去和这三个国家的其他领导人坐在一起，几乎坐不直，更不用说，你知道，有力地为你所相信的事情辩护吗？所以一个大问题，我的意思是，这有点陈述事实，但我还是想以这个音符结束，但是，你无法选择大流行病何时来袭，对吧？我认为这触及了一个更大的主题，即，你知道，总统任期的大部分时间是由你无法计划的事情所定义的。这真的关乎你在那一刻如何反应。我的意思是，这似乎是一个完美的例子。是的。我的意思是，当时的倾向是，正确的事情是淡化正在发生的事情
because people have just come through this horrifying war. The last thing that they need is to be told that there's this other invisible enemy that's going to kill millions of them. But of course, what we learn from it is when you don't have a handle on it, when you don't tell people what's happening, it actually just leads to even worse outcomes. And that's what happened. I mean, the press at the time was censoring news of this pandemic. And that's not the only reason that millions and millions of people died, but it was a
因为人们刚刚经历了这场可怕的战争。他们最不需要的就是被告知还有另一个会杀死他们数百万人的隐形敌人。但当然，我们从中了解到的是，当你无法掌控它，当你没有告诉人们正在发生什么时，它实际上只会导致更糟糕的结果。这就是发生的事情。我的意思是，当时的媒体在审查这场大流行病的新闻。这并不是数以百万计的人死亡的唯一原因，但它是一个
contributing factor. So, I guess one more question on the flu itself. I mean, if the public had somehow known, I guess this happens relatively late that he gets it, but I'm trying to imagine, you know, do these moments where like, oh my gosh, a president got this. Do those break through? I mean, do those make a difference? I think they do make a difference in the sense that you see that no one has the power or the money to avoid it, right? Like, it's one of those things that you can't negotiate your way out of. Like, we're all vulnerable to it. I do think it's fair at the same time though that like seeing a president
促成因素。所以，我想再问一个关于流感本身的问题。我的意思是，如果公众以某种方式知道了，我想他患病的时间相对较晚，但我试图想象，你知道，这些时刻，比如，天哪，总统得了这个病。这些时刻会产生影响吗？我的意思是，它们会有所不同吗？我认为它们确实有所不同，因为你看到没有人有权力和金钱来避免它，对吧？就像，这是你无法通过谈判摆脱的事情之一。就像，我们都容易受到它的影响。但我确实认为，与此同时，看到一位总统
Stricken with something like this can scare people Particularly at a time when they're already pretty scared. It can be destabilizing There's this little meme or whatever you want to call it floating around around like people use this term Like we must protect so and so and I think it was pre- like people use this term, like we must protect so and so and I think it was pre-pandemic, but now people are saying, you know, we must protect, pick, you know, Beyonce or whoever, but also, you know, politicians, like,
被这样的事情折磨会吓到人们，特别是在他们已经相当害怕的时候。这可能会破坏稳定。有一个小梗或者你想怎么称呼它，在人们中间流传，比如人们使用这个词，比如我们必须保护某某某，我想这是在大流行之前，但现在人们在说，你知道，我们必须保护，挑选，你知道，碧昂丝（Beyonce）或者其他任何人，但也包括，你知道，政客们，比如，
we have to keep these people healthy so that they can do their jobs because their jobs have massive ramifications. Yeah, I mean, let's just put it out there. Ruth Bader Ginsburg, if somebody people have been trying to wrap in bubble wraps since three years ago, and again, like it's been a powerful meme to say like, do you want to be the person who gave this to a person who gave it to Ruth Bader Ginsburg? Oh, wow, I hadn't really heard that framing, but yeah, I guess that's something to think
我们必须保持这些人健康，这样他们才能做好他们的工作，因为他们的工作有巨大的影响。是的，我的意思是，让我们把它摆出来。鲁斯·巴德·金斯伯格（Ruth Bader Ginsburg），如果有人从三年前开始就一直试图把她包裹在气泡膜里，而且再次强调，这是一个强有力的梗，说，你想成为那个把病毒传给鲁斯·巴德·金斯伯格的人吗？哦，哇，我还没真正听说过这种说法，但是的，我想这是值得思考的事情
about. Okay, we're going to wrap it up there. But first, a few other things that happened on this day, April 2nd, in other years. In 1870, the first female candidate for president, Victoria Woodhall, announced her candidacy by writing a letter to the editor of the New York Herald. 1917, Janet Rankin was sworn in as the first female congressman, and in 1964, on April 2nd, Malcolm X gave his ballot or the bullet speech. So every once in a while, we'll give you a taste of other things that happened on this day.
好的，我们就在这里结束吧。但首先，在这一天，4月2日，在其他年份还发生了一些其他事情。1870年，第一位女性总统候选人维多利亚·伍德哈尔（Victoria Woodhall）通过写信给《纽约先驱报》编辑宣布了她的候选资格。1917年，珍妮特·兰金（Janet Rankin）宣誓就职成为第一位女性国会议员，而在1964年4月2日，马尔科姆·X（Malcolm X）发表了他的“选票还是子弹”演讲。所以每隔一段时间，我们就会让你尝尝在这一天发生的其他事情。
By the way, this is what we're doing on our social feeds as well posting a few times a day about other things that happened. So make sure you check those out. Alright Nicole, himmer. Thank you as always. This was great. Thanks, Judy. This day in esoteric political history is a proud member of radio topia from PRX. Our researcher and producer is Jacob Feldman. If you have any ideas for an upcoming topic or a date, get in touch. You can let us know a specific date or just a rough topic that you want us to talk about and we can find a peg for it. You can email us this day pod at gmail.com. There's also a contact form at thisdaypod.com. Next episode we're jumping to the more recent past 2008 Barack Obama and a comment he made about rural voters that may have said a lot about where politics was going over the next decade. You know, we've been talking about this for a couple of months and this was just going
顺便说一句，这也是我们在社交媒体上所做的，每天发布几次关于发生的其他事情。所以一定要去看看。好的，妮可·哈默。一如既往地感谢你。这太棒了。谢谢，朱迪。《This day in esoteric political history》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的骄傲成员。我们的研究员和制片人是雅各布·费尔德曼。如果你对即将到来的主题或日期有任何想法，请与我们联系。你可以告诉我们一个具体的日期，或者只是一个你想让我们谈论的大致主题，我们可以找到一个切入点。你可以发邮件给我们 this day pod at gmail.com。在thisdaypod.com上也有一个联系表单。下一集我们将跳到更近的过去，2008年巴拉克·奥巴马（Barack Obama）关于农村选民的评论，这可能对未来十年政治的发展方向说明了很多。你知道，我们已经谈论这个几个月了，这本来只是
to be about the election and just use historical precedent to help describe the moment that we're in in terms of the election. And then coronavirus pandemic started and we decided to move up the launch date a week. And so how are you thinking about the stories you will be selecting over this season while this is going on? I mean you know I do want to make space for stories not just oh we're gonna find stories of health crises or pandemics but stories of just moments of national crisis. I mean I think we are we are in a moment clearly of national crisis. I think, I think we are in a moment clearly of national
关于选举，只是利用历史先例来帮助描述我们目前所处的选举时刻。然后冠状病毒大流行开始了，我们决定将发布日期提前一周。那么你是如何考虑在这个赛季中选择故事的呢？我的意思是，你知道，我确实想为故事留出空间，不仅仅是哦，我们要寻找健康危机或大流行病的故事，而是关于国家危机时刻的故事。我的意思是，我认为我们显然正处于一个国家危机的时刻。我想，我想我们显然正处于一个
crisis. I think we are going to enter a moment of, you know, what I've been thinking of as sort of civic creativity or civic rear range room. We're really going to have to think through how our society is ordered and what our norms are. And politics is a space in which, you know, we do that. And we've had to do that for better or worse. And so I think making space to talk about moments where we've done that, not just necessarily linked to an election year. That said, I will say that my co-host, Nikki Hammer, who's a political historian,
危机。我认为我们将进入一个时刻，你知道，我一直在思考这是一种公民创造力或公民重组。我们真的必须深入思考我们的社会是如何构建的，以及我们的规范是什么。政治是一个我们进行这些思考的空间。无论好坏，我们都必须这样做。所以我认为，创造空间来谈论我们曾经这样做过的时刻，不仅仅是与选举年相关，这一点很重要。话虽如此，我要说的是，我的联合主持人尼基·哈默（Nikki Hammer）是一位政治历史学家，
when we were talking about making this change and expanding the scope a little bit, she pointed out, and she was like, elections have never really been normal. Most elections are huge. Most elections are kind of feel like they have crisis and so forth. And so even if we had stuck to just the election lens, we would have had plenty of big huge moments where it felt like, oh my gosh, our country is tearing itself apart or or tarot being torn apart. So, you know, I also do want
当我们谈论做出这种改变并稍微扩大范围时，她指出，她说，选举从来都不是真正正常的。大多数选举都是重大的。大多数选举让人感觉好像有危机等等。所以即使我们只坚持选举的视角，我们也会有很多重大的时刻，让人觉得，天哪，我们的国家正在分崩离析，或者正在被撕裂。所以，你知道，我也想
to say though, it's very important to me to also just find small moments and moments that just are interesting. And I think we can find lessons in those, even if we don't go out of our way to find big moments or big lessons and so forth, just telling a good small story from our political past, I think we'll still resonate and I want to make space for the esoteric. It's not just going to be meltdowns and influenza and so forth. And we're going to find some quote unquote fun and interesting stories as we go as well. And you're going to do some of that on your social media accounts and stuff like that,
说，对我来说，找到一些小的时刻和仅仅是有趣的时刻也非常重要。我认为我们可以在这些时刻中找到教训，即使我们不刻意去寻找重大的时刻或重大的教训等等，仅仅是从我们的政治历史中讲述一个好的小故事，我认为仍然会引起共鸣，我想为深奥的内容留出空间。这不仅仅是关于崩溃、流感等等。我们也会在前进的过程中找到一些所谓的有趣的故事。你也会在你的社交媒体账户上做一些这样的事情，
rather than just the podcast. Yeah. So on social media, we're going to be posting a few times a day actually about all the stuff that we don't get to. We only get to do one topic per day, but we research to tons. So just throughout the day and throughout the week on social media, on Twitter and Instagram, we're just posting about so and so happened this day, so and so happened that day. And I will say, we've already got that going, and I have found it really interesting, and some of the stuff is
而不是仅仅在播客上。是的。所以在社交媒体上，我们实际上每天会发布几次关于我们无法涵盖的所有内容。我们每天只能做一个主题，但我们做了大量的研究。所以就在全天和整个星期里，在社交媒体上，在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上，我们只是发布关于某某人在这一天发生了什么，某某人在那一天发生了什么。我要说的是，我们已经开始了，我发现这真的很有趣，而且有些东西
posted, I didn't post our producer posts in, sort of caught me off guard, and I said, oh my gosh, you know, on this day, we announced that we had a polio vaccine, or on this day, the Navy SEALs were formed, and just little tidbits that make you stop and think and try your own little lessons or whatever. And so I'm actually pretty excited about the social media stuff we've got going on as well. Yeah. You know, you were involved, you were in the Brian Lair show, and you were on 538. You often react to things in real time and are the producer and host of these discussions. Have you missed that role during this period of time when things are happening or have you been happy to not be part of it in the direct conversation?
发布了，不是我发布的，是我们的制作人发布的，有点让我措手不及，我说，天哪，你知道，在这一天，我们宣布我们有了脊髓灰质炎疫苗，或者在这一天，海豹突击队成立了，这些小片段让你停下来思考，并尝试你自己的小教训什么的。所以我对我们正在进行的社交媒体内容也感到非常兴奋。是的。你知道，你参与过 Brian Lair 节目，也上过 538。你经常实时对事物做出反应，并且是这些讨论的制作人和主持人。在这段时间里，当事情发生时，你是否错过了那个角色，或者你很高兴没有直接参与对话？
I mean, I think both. I mean, I think anyone who is a journalist when there's a big story and someone who believes in, the journalism has a role, it's been tough to for me to feel a little bit like I'm sitting on the sidelines. But I also think that stories like these, looking to history, stories that kind of talk to a moment, but not necessarily about a moment, are really important. And so I do feel like this is my chance to
我的意思是，我认为两者都有。我的意思是，我认为任何一个记者，当有大新闻时，以及任何一个相信新闻业有作用的人，对我来说，感觉自己有点像坐在场边是很难受的。但我也认为，像这样的故事，回顾历史，谈论一个时刻但未必是关于那个时刻的故事，是非常重要的。所以我确实觉得这是我的机会，
engage in my chance to contribute something. Going into this year, I sort of thought, well, do I want to cover this election again in the sort of day-to-day way I did for in 2016 and the three elections before that and I basically decided no I mean I like to sleep. I have a kid now. It was like 2016 you know took a few years off my life and and so this feels like a good balance. This day in esoteric political history is produced by Jody Evergan and Jacob Feldman. It's new from Radio Topia. A new episode comes out every Tuesday and Thursday we'll have links to subscribe
参与其中，这是我贡献一些东西的机会。进入今年，我心想，我是否想以 2016 年和之前三次选举的那种日常方式再次报道这次选举？我基本上决定不，我的意思是，我喜欢睡觉。我现在有个孩子。这就像 2016 年，你知道，从我的生命中夺走了几年，所以这感觉是一个很好的平衡。《这一天的深奥政治历史》由 Jody Evergan 和 Jacob Feldman 制作。这是 Radio Topia 的新节目。每周二和周四都会有新的一集，我们将提供订阅链接
in the show notes in our website. So I have one kind of self-serving public service announcement because people are not commuting as much, podcasts, listenership is down, not by much, like 5% or so. But the thing is, this is part of the economy that you can support without spending a dime. If you go through the 99pi catalog and download or stream, just one extra episode this week, that 5% decrease will be eliminated and will maybe even see an overall
在节目说明和我们的网站上。所以我有一个自私的公共服务公告，因为人们通勤不像以前那么多了，播客的收听率下降了，虽然不多，大概 5% 左右。但问题是，这是经济的一部分，你可以在不花一分钱的情况下支持它。如果你浏览 99pi 目录并下载或流式传输本周额外的一集，那 5% 的下降就会被消除，我们甚至可能会看到整体的
increase. Or you know, you can go download and listen the whole omnipos and pick one episode to send to friends. People seem to really like that at home episode I did a couple weeks ago, so maybe send that one around. The point is, this is the thing where a free and joyful task could do a lot of good and keep the show healthy and strong. So thanks. If you do heed the call and listen extra and spread the word, you know tag me on Twitter and I'll thank you personally. 99% invisible is a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is physically distributed in multiple locations but in our heart it's still in beautiful, downtown,
增长。或者你知道，你可以去下载并收听整个节目，然后挑选一集发给朋友。人们似乎非常喜欢我几周前做的那个关于家庭的一集，所以也许可以转发那一集。重点是，这是一件免费且令人愉快的事情，可以做很多好事，并保持节目的健康和强大。所以谢谢。如果你听从了呼吁，多听一点并传播出去，你知道在 Twitter 上标记我，我会亲自感谢你。《99% 无形》是旧金山 91.7K ALW 的一个项目，在 Radio Row 制作，它在多个地点进行物理分发，但在我们心中，它仍然在美丽的市中心，
Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, run Instagram and write it too. But you can peruse old episodes and share those episodes
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的骄傲成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @Roman Mars，在 99PI org 关注该节目，在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。但你可以浏览旧剧集并分享这些剧集
with your friends at 99PI.org. Radio Topeo. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与你的朋友在 99PI.org。Radio Topia。来自 PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。